what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today i'm
reacting to andrew tate why i get caught
cheating on purpose before i start don't
forget to subscribe to the channel bring
that notification bell that way you're
going to be subscribed for my daily
videos
okay let's go
fem-centric systems
enslave
man i saw some dude the other day some
guy on twitter he's a big bitcoin guy
he's him and his [ __ ] wife and his
head kid yay my kid i got kid did it in
days of old any dude with money
he spread his genetic seed everywhere
he'd have 50 kids with [ __ ] 30 chicks
but now he's gonna have a couple kids
with one chick why
okay this is an interesting argument in
the manosphere the argument basically is
since
at one period in our history this is how
things were done this is how we should
always do it
and you know maybe that's nice in
theory
but
it doesn't really make sense to me
not because that's what he truly wants
because the woman will get mad if he
doesn't that's the other thing about the
man of sphere the second argument i
always see he doesn't really want that
women just tell him what to want so
therefore he thinks that
um
it's just interesting because a lot a
lot of the manosphere is this is how i
see the world
and
if anyone tells me difference because
either a woman told them to
or a woman
is influencing them
or or
they're they're trying to sleep with the
woman so therefore they think that the
female controls in the female inherited
well my wife might leave me and cry her
eyes out if i get my pp wet
you got a [ __ ] chick telling you what
to do with your own dick
you got women controlling your body
parts
minafi listen to them
so
what me and tristan do is very very
important by attempting to rebalance the
universe with our aikido please
understand there's no you have to
realize do these men come off like they
have happy healthy and fulfilling
relationships a lot of social media is a
facade guys and i don't know why
it's just a vibe i get it's a feeling
and i know
you know they always say women operate
on feelings but we also operate off of
social cues and i can just tell when
people are capping and when people talk
in a certain way and act a certain way
it's more of a show than it is like who
they really are
no female on the planet who would not be
a loving loyal subservient girlfriend to
men of our caliber
of course there's nowhere else to
[ __ ] go but i
oh my god me
i like me as in like i would not do that
no thank you
um
i'm good refuse to allow that to happen
you can either buy yourself a nice
reliable toyota or you can buy yourself
a mclaren and all its problems because
when you have the best of the best
problems come with it i refuse to allow
some [ __ ] to get a reliable mclaren in
me
in fact
i'm so offended [ __ ] being loyal i'm
offended if a [ __ ] thinks i'm loyal
well you think i have no hoes
do i look a [ __ ] punk to you
so
for that reason
guys some people if
people on the internet love drama
why on earth would you go out of your
way to show your girlfriend or wife or
whoever that you have hoes
like do you need a hobby sir
to re-establish balance in the universe
because of this [ __ ] [ __ ] i just saw on
twitter
he's not going to have 20 songs he's
afraid of his [ __ ] wife like a loser
what i'm going to do is invite all of my
girlfriends some of them have already
met some of them don't know the others
okay wait
andrew tate children
andrew tate net worth okay blah blah
blah don't care don't care
don't care
six
um
personal life
he's he's roasting this guy about not
having enough sons he better have a kid
personal life okay
um okay i do not see anything
no children sir where are your 20 sons
where are they all of them to the house
today
and when i say all of them
i mean all of them
who hasn't gone strong
to everyone so they can all sit there
who's this girl
listen you little [ __ ]
if you think a man like me has to be
loyal to some stupid whoopee like you
you're your [ __ ] mind you realize
that a lot of guys are loyal because
they don't want to take the time to deal
with more than one girl
it's a lot of effort to maintain eight
different relationships
like a lot of guys are just out there
building skills and making money and
don't have time for this stuff you have
to realize guys a lot of the internet is
just a facade and as women we have this
gut feeling when someone
their persona is a facade now is it
right is it wrong i don't know
but i told you guys that fresh and fit
did not seem like they got girls way
before anything came out right i i
called that months months ago
and
when he talks i just get this gut
feeling of like something is not genuine
i don't know what
um could not tell you what it is but
it just seems like he does all this
stuff to make money on youtube and put
on this facade for men to like
want to be and chase after
rather than doing it because it's
practical and makes sense you know just
because at one point in history we did
things a certain way it doesn't mean
it's practical
in 2021
at one point it was frowned upon for me
to show my ankles
and in 2021 there are girls and thongs
on the beach
things change over time and i just don't
it doesn't seem like that's a good
argument because there's a lot of things
that happen at one point in history that
logically don't make sense today i've
been through a fraction of the [ __ ] i've
been through to become the man i am
you're nothing
you're a little [ __ ] whoopi what are
you oh
who the [ __ ] doesn't i don't care i'm
bringing all of them and this is the
test of loyalty and also look at the
wait for it wait for because if you
won't remain loyal to me while i cheat
on you with eight girls in front of your
face then i don't need you
if you won't remain loyal to me while i
cheat on you with eight girls in front
of your face then i don't need you
okay sir
like like imagine the type of guy that
wants to have a party with eight women
why would he want to do that
drama
it creates drama it creates energy for
youtube or content for youtube
a lot of guys work 60 70 80 hours a week
they don't have time for this stuff so
to combat this defense centric systems
of earth tristan we have to invite every
single girl that we are currently dating
to the house at once
and if they want to cry about it
[Music]
okay now
this is going to be very judgmental this
is going to be very judgmental but the
ideal in the manosphere
is a conservative woman right like that
seems to be conservative housewife like
girl that doesn't really need attention
and validation from the internet that
stays in they tend to like shy girls
what are they wearing
is this is this the ideal woman that
these
dating masterminds can get
if they want to cry about it i'm a fair
man
so because i'm fair if they want to cry
and they want to get upset i will offer
any single one of them fair guys don't
jump in
one-on-one combat don't jump in that's
fair one-on-one if you're really that
upset you want to scream in my face
that's fine we can have one-on-one
combat outside if you win i'll get rid
of the other girls but if you lose you
can take your busted up eye and get the
[ __ ] out of my house
oh my gosh this man is crazy people on
the internet
just live wild lives i swear so they can
talk about it on youtube a wrong one um
but let me know what you think in the
comments i think that
anyone is welcome to live their lives
any
way that they choose but there's a
reason
that the most successful and powerful
men on earth have a wife
it's because it makes sense for what
reason let me know in the comments
thank you for watching guys please
subscribe if you've watched three of my
videos and you have not subscribed
subscribed yet we have beef so please
i'll talk to you guys next time